this is before only fans is before
instagram blac chyna was like a legend
when we think of like miami strip clubs
like she was like one of them names you
would hear people rap about and then
i mean but he
i would say it's the other way around
you know what i'm saying and i'll do be
joking the clown and clowning with her
or whatever the case may be so if you
ever see this like
so
she made him
that's what i think cause she was she
was that [ __ ] you know i'm saying that
[ __ ] she was that [ __ ] you had to go
request her to come out drake was
already then said her name and song she
was stripping she was doing her thing
[ __ ] was that kod [ __ ] she was that
[ __ ] right you know i'm saying so and
rack city just came out you feel me we
just came out we was doing our thing it
was buzzing so boom he like he like man
i need to go get this [ __ ] so i felt
like you know it was only right to have
the top-notch stripper [ __ ] or you know
a [ __ ] doing her thing to elevate your
[ __ ] couples and to me you know so when
you're in a relationship it elevates you
right so and with them two being
together like true it was crazy you feel
me like she crazy stripper [ __ ] doing
the [ __ ] partying drugs doing all the
[ __ ] she turned that little [ __ ]
out me
she turned that [ __ ] out on god in
heaven she put him on little kid
all kinds of wild [ __ ] one day he look
he's like man we gotta go get her we go
to miami [ __ ] we request her [ __ ] the
whole tour bus get off the bus we go to
the club we only going there to request
her she comes out [ __ ] he has a stack
of money in his hand i'm like this is yo
this is make a break we wasn't even
trying to enjoy the club we already knew
what was happening boom she came out
went up spoke to him he just handed her
the money we shook i'm like you got the
number you did all the she like got a
number i'm like how much money
it probably was like
500 or something like that but it looked
crazy you know the ones look crazy you
know it's like whatever so he told her
all right cool got her number
called her right after he caught her
because he caught he's like come being a
rack city video
and then she flew down came to be in the
rack city video and in vegas this was
in los angeles downtown wait but wasn't
there an original rack city video that
was shot in vegas and he shot it over
yeah that was like that was like the
world star video yeah then he had to
shoot it over because the [ __ ] was
booming you know what i'm saying the
record labels start getting behind it
put the budget behind it shot it over
brought her out and that was all she
wrote